bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour un
nouveau numéro de dimanche en politique
émission spéciale bourgogne franche
comté aujourd'hui à une semaine du
premier tour de la primaire de la droite
qui va être désigné son candidat ou sa
candidate à l'élection présidentielle
cette candidature en lice donc et sur ce
plateau des représentants des quatre
premières pour l'instant d'après les
sondages
bonjour à nos d'argent bonjour vous êtes
député européen et vous soutenez dans
cette primaire alain juppé alain
chrétien vous êtes député maire de
vesoul en haute-saône bonjour bonjour et
c'est bruno le maire que vous soutenez
jean marie sermier vous êtes député
maire de dole dans le jura bonjour
bonjour vous portez dans cette primaire
les couleurs de françois fillon enfin
gilles platret bonjour bonjour vous êtes
le maire de chalon sur saône et vous
soutenez nicolas sarkozy sont aussi
candidats dans cette primaire jean
françois copé nathalie kosciusko morizet
et jean frédéric poisson
la semaine a bien sûr été marquée par le
coup de tonnerre américain l'élection de
donald trump très vite plusieurs
candidats à la primaire en ont tiré des
leçons ou des conclusions assez
différente il faut le dire
est il bien raisonnable dans le contexte
français de faire des liens à la craie
tient à ce que tout cela est
transposable
ben je vous savez les électeurs qu'ils
soient américains ou français sont avant
tout des gens qui font des choix est
parfois les conséquences sont les mêmes
causes et aujourd'hui on se rend compte
que les clinton ont été rejetées après
trente ans de vie politique oui pensait
maîtriser le système politico médiatique
les sondages se sont trompés et aussi et
je crois que les méthodes sont les mêmes
aux états unis ou en france donc on
devra sans doute de grosses surprises
aussi aux élections des primaires et
aussi des présidentielles mais plus plus
brièvement je crois qu'il ya un gros
problème dans ce qu'on appelle le
populisme non le populisme c'est surtout
d'écouter les peuples et j'ai
l'impression que hillary clinton
n'écoutait plus les américains depuis
longtemps c'est pour ça qu'ils ont
choisi quelqu'un d'autre
gilles platret nicolas sarkozy a parlé
d'un refus d'une pensée unique est ce
que c'est une stratégie pour imiter
donald trump et en tirer le même
bénéfice
je sais pas si ces limitations mais
quand on a un candidat comme tron qui
est rejetée par 98 % des médias qui est
donné perdant dans pratiquement toutes
les enquêtes d'opinion jusqu'au dernière
et qui finit par gagner la maison
blanche
il faut quand même qu'on se pose des
questions tout est pas transposable
entre les états unis et nous
et j'entends d'ailleurs que d'autres
candidats à l'extrême droite voudrait
tirer parti trump inspirer confiance
d'abord parce que c'est un capitaine
d'industrie
même s'il a fait des faillites mais il a
conduit une grosse affaire et ce à
rassurer les américains
et puis je pense très sincèrement
aujourd'hui que il a fait la
démonstration et le peuple avec lui 58
millions d'américains qui ont voté pour
lui que on pouvait seriné toujours la
même chose
empêcher les uns de dire ce qu'ils
pensaient quand ils disent qu'ils
pensent y gagne les élections c'est un
peu la stratégie qui est la nôtre aussi
arnaud danjean al'inverse j'allais dire
alain juppé a pointé les risques de la
démagogie et de l'extrémisme
c'est une autre conclusion qui raid
américain parce que là vous prenez
simplement une phrase du communiqué
d'alain juppé non sur le phénomène
trucks moi je dirais trois choses la
première c'est que tout est possible et
on le voit par rapport effectivement à
la faillite des enquêtes d'opinion donc
tout est possible et rien n'est fait et
donc c'est très bien et pour cette
primaire si on veut transposer tout est
effectivement possible parce qu'en plus
on joue sur un corps électoral qui est
totalement inconnu et virtuels personne
ne sait quelle sera la participation et
la participation sera la clé de beaucoup
de choses premièrement deuxièmement
trump candidat antisystème antisystème
les milliardaires quand même
donc moi je veux bien les classes
populaires mais quand vous regardez
vraiment les couches les plus aisées de
la population au vote et rome quand vous
regardez le donc quand la quantité anti
système qui arrive derrière clinton sur
le vote global donc les transpositions
sont un peu difficiles d'autant que
parmi nous excuser moi mes chers
collègues il n'y a pas de candidat
antisystème
parmi les républicains en tout cas tout
le monde a été au pouvoir un moment ou
un autre il n'y a pas de candidat du
système
et puis troisièmement ce qui sera très
intéressant trump ne prendra ses
fonctions qu'à la fin janvier
et je crains pour ma part qui a encore
beaucoup de déconnexion pour le meilleur
et pour le pire entre ce qu'il a dit
pendant sa campagne et ce qui va faire
et ce phénomène là on verra aussi la
transposition en france parce que la
défiance principal de nos électeurs
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on ne fait pas ce
qu'on dit entre le moment la campagne et
le moment où on est au pouvoir et je
crois que trump échappera difficilement
à syndrome marie sermier beaucoup de
deux observateurs parlent aussi d'un
effet aux états unis
la mondialisation comme on l'avait dit
au moment du break site c'est une
analyse qu'on peut faire sur ce sur ce
scrutin américain quant au soutien à la
démocratie
on ne commande pas après les élections
je veux dire il faut respecter les
peuples il faut respecter leur choix
et puis pour ce qui est arrivé aux
etats-unis moi ça me fait penser que les
primaires dans les démocraties où on
organise des primaires avant les
élections sont essentielles puisque
finalement trump a gagné son ticket au
cours de la primaire des républicains où
il a sillonné les états unis où il avait
contre lui d'autres candidats où il a
finalement émergé et il avait des rires
lui l'essentiel du parti républicain
alors avant de faire le avant le premier
tour cette primaire ont modestement
essayer d'aider ceux qui se posent la
question à choisir avec quelques sujets
on va essayer de concret rapide parce
qu'on n'a pas beaucoup de temps
forcément on est le 13 novembre il ya un
an c'était les attentats de paris alain
chrétien vous étiez d'ailleurs avec nous
une semaine après pour une émission
spéciale face au terrorisme
si vous êtes élu si le votre champion
pardon est élu savez vous comment éviter
nouveau 13 novembre et 14 juillet est ce
que certains d'entre vous ont des
solutions différentes
arnaud danjean c'est un sujet que vous
connaissez bien moi je vais répéter elle
ajouté fera quoi eh bien d'abord on ne
combat pas le terrorisme à coup de
grandes déclarations et la surenchère
qui peut y avoir dans les déclarations
toutes plus martial les unes que les
autres à chaque fois que nous sommes
frappés par le terrorisme
ça ne résout rien la seule chose qu'ils
combattent efficacement le terrorisme
c'est l'action et c'est l'action de
trois institutions en france lorsque
nous sommes dans une démocratie c'est
l'action coordonnée des services de
renseignements avant tout avant tout
parce que l'anti terrorisme c'est
d'abord du renseignement la police et la
justice
sur ces trois volets là il ya du travail
à faire le gouvernement n'a pas tout
fait ce qu'il était possible de faire
pour bien articuler ces trois dimensions
mais je le répète le travail fondamental
c'est le travail du renseignement
renseignements territoriale
élargissement et décloisonnement de nos
services de renseignements qu'ils
travaillent encore beaucoup trop en silo
nous avons désarmé une partie de notre
arsenal de renseignement depuis des
années notamment au plus près du terrain
pour percevoir ce qu'on appelle les
signaux faibles qui sont ceux qui
inquiètent le plus nos concitoyens en
bourgogne franche comté on n'est pas
dans un territoire après
youri exposés aux touristes mais on
l'est alain chrétien le sait bien vague
de radicalisation à vesoul
une douzaine de vesoul liens qui sont
partis en irak et en syrie
donc il faut investir massivement dans
notre renseignement il faut travailler
entre renseignement police et justice la
responsable doit être également beaucoup
plus ferme
même si d'un point de vue législatif je
ne suis pas certain qu'il faille se
lancer dans une inflation de mesures il
ya aussi un vrai lien entre terrorisme
et délinquance il faut l'admettre on a
fait l'erreur
ces dix dernières années de baisser la
garde avec la baisse importante du
nombre de policiers du nombre de
gendarmes
la déstructuration du renseignement
territoriale et là aussi on a notre part
de responsabilité il faut donc
reconquérir des territoires de non droit
qui existe des molunes bec il y en a en
france il y en a des dizaines en france
arnaud a raison de rappeler qu' on a des
djihadistes qui sont y compris dans nos
campagnes les plus profondes ce n'est
pas qu'une question de quartiers urbains
et donc on a baissé la garde avec un
certain angélisme avec une certaine
naïveté et donc il faudra redonner de me
des moyens puissants des moyens
extrêmement forges était sur le pont de
la concorde devant l'assemblée nationale
quand les policiers manifestaient savez
vous que quand dans un procès verbal on
écrit douze en chiffres arabes
pardon est pas en lettres le procès
verbal peut être annulé pour vice de
forme
savez vous que maintenant les avocats
sont là dès la première minute dès les
gardes à vue le mot que j'ai envie de
vous de relance et qui vous permettra de
rebondir cet état de droit est ce que
pour vous la limite c'est le problème en
deux ça au delà et je regarde gilles
platret parce que il faudra qu'il
réponde là dessus après problème n'est
pas là on se lance des grandes des
grands slows alain figure est adroit pas
état de droit l'état de droit doit
protéger les français
s'il faut le modifier pour protéger les
français modifions le une justice
d'exception
oui parce que nous sommes dans une
situation d'exception qui nécessite des
moyens renforcés plus de moyens
juridiques et plus de moyens matériels
cet essentiel ne baissons pas la garde
je le disais j'ai pl 13 je prenais une
phrase d'un du meeting de meyzieu
nicolas sarkozy je ne serai pas le
président qui s'abritera derrière l'état
de droit pour ne pas prendre les mesures
qui s'imposent ça veut dire que voilà
sarkozy est prêt à aller plus loin que
les autres candidats à la primaire sur
un certain nombre de points très
clairement elle se mêler nous sommes en
guerre
quand j'entends qu'il ne faut pas faire
de déclarations martiales alors que nous
sommes en période de guerre je me dis
qu'on se trompe de chemin
nous sommes en guerre contre un ennemi
qui non seulement commandes agite depuis
l'extérieur des éléments déterminés
qu'ils sont prêts à passer à l'action et
nicolas sarkozy sur ce point veut
appliquer le principe de précaution
qu'on applique partout ailleurs sauf ici
et c'est donc l'examen de chaque
individu présumé dangereux pour savoir
si oui ou non il faut l'interné
préventivement ça c'est une mesure
nouvelle effectivement qui n'est pas
dans notre droit aujourd'hui sinon pour
des cas particuliers il dit sont plus
des cas médicaux qui devra qui devra
susciter une modification une refonte on
est viré accord notre arsenal juridique
on est d'accord et c'est là où je
réponds à votre question l'état de droit
c'est celui qui protège la société
c'est celui qui protège les victimes ou
celles qui peuvent le devenir et pas les
coupables
donc l'état de droit c'est celui qui est
fort lorsque la france est en guerre
mais ça suffira pas monsieur roy il sert
aussi à protéger les innocents d'un
certain nombre de cas il protège les
innocents ils protègent des innocents y
compris les 238 victimes que nous avons
eu l'année dernière sera et nous dont
nous fêtons hélas nous commémorons la
disparition le 1er anniversaire
aujourd'hui même vous le savez bien ce
qui est important c'est pas de réduire
la chasse aux terroristes uniquement à
la lutte anti jihadistes il y a dans nos
sociétés ça a été dit tout à l'heure des
individus qui sont sous la coupe de
l'islam politique qui sont en train de
s'acclimater à une image de la france
qui n'est pas celle que nous souhaitons
est ce que nicolas sarkozy propose que
nous souhaitons avec lui c'est
précisément que nous luttions non
seulement contre l'islam djihadistes
mais l'islam politique tout court
et là il ya un gros travail j'ai mis en
place à chalon une cellule municipal des
chances sur la radicalisation et l'état
je peux vous dire que dans les villes
tranquille
il ya un mouvement ce moment même dans
les petites villes les villes moyennes
et qu'il faut être très très vigilant là
dessus
ce dernier cas la position de très
clairement c'est un ensemble de mesures
évidemment donc il s'agit de mettre des
moyens supplémentaires et je crois que
façon françois fillon l'a très bien dit
12 milliards d'euros supplémentaires sur
la police sur la gendarmerie sur les
forces de sécurité intérieures il s'agit
d'impliquer les maires je crois que mes
collègues les zombies aujourd'hui nous
devrions être plus appliqués par rapport
au fichier s et puis il s'agit aussi de
combattre des ch
là où il est et je pense que françois
fillon a été un des premiers à évoquer
la responsabilité des états la nécessité
d'avoir des alliances et notamment avec
la russie
il faut à tout prix que nous puissions
voir un certain nombre d'alliances pour
combattre des ch là où il est et le
réduire à néant
on va avancer sur la dimension des
finances publiques qui est important
dans vos programmes
mais j'avais envie de vous le présenter
en réfléchissant aussi au regard de ce
qui s'est passé aux états unis on a
beaucoup dit qu'une partie qui s'est
passé aux états unis est liée à des
zones intermédiaires délaissé on parle
beaucoup en france aussi aujourd'hui de
la situation des petites villes des
campagnes on note que pour tous les
candidats à la primaire quasiment il ya
la volonté de tenir le budget du pays de
ne pas dépenser trop de faire un certain
nombre d'économies y compris et et je
pense à françois fillon là dessus avec
eux voilà avec aussi la suppression d'un
certain nombre de fonctionnaires
comment est-ce qu'on peut tenir le
budget du pays supprimer des
fonctionnaires et en même temps par les
eaux à la demande des gens des petites
villes des campagnes qui sont abandonnés
en partie par l'état
alors il est clair aujourd'hui les
sachants bruno le maire veut pas
forcément être aussi rigoureux que les
autres si j'ai bien compris en terme de
budget silva qui veut se garder des
marges dans le contrat présidentiel que
bruno le maire a proposé et a contraint
très précis d'ailleurs je crois que
c'est le plus précis l'institut
montaigne a fait une évaluation et je
crois que c'est plus précis de tous les
candidats
il est clair que l'état ne peut plus
tout faire l'état doit se recentrer sur
ses missions régaliennes on l'a évoqué
lutte contre le terrorisme sécurité il
faut de l'ordre dans notre pays il faut
qu'on fasse confiance confiance aux
acteurs locaux confiance aux élus locaux
confiance aux entreprises et aux
salariés il faut redonner cette ce
pouvoir de dialogue sur le terrain et
depuis trop longtemps les socialistes
ont fait l'état intervient sur tout
partout dispendieux et dépensent
beaucoup d'argent donc un état moins
présent sur des missions qu'il ne
maîtrise plus on a vu les
circonvolutions sur alstom sur les
grandes entreprises nationales et un
état qui soit plus efficace sur les
règles les plus simples et redonner le
pouvoir aux élus locaux et aux salariés
et l'entreprise c'est une révolution
enfin là moi je parle d'argent et par le
nombre de fonctionnaires si vous n'allez
plus de fonctionnaires il c'est un
sergent de gym qui n'aurait plus
aujourd'hui qui a le taux de
fonctionnarisation le plus élevé de
l'union européenne
supprimer un certain nombre de
fonctionnaires ça n'est pas supprimé
l'ensemble des services à la population
donc je crois qu'il faut faire attention
effectivement françois fillon l'a dit
110 milliards d'économies et je crois
que c'est pas la qualité d'un programme
ça n'est pas une réflexion tout
simplement pour pouvoir remporter une
élection c'est très clairement la
nécessité de devoir réduire notre train
de vie pour permettre à notre pays de
continuer si nous continuons à 7
à ce rythme là les dépenses de l'état et
bien dans quelques années nous serons
même plus capable de pouvoir financer le
remboursement des emprunts pour le
fonctionnement pendant un point très
important
la lutte contre les déficits publics et
la dette c'est pas pour le plaisir et
pas pour le plaisir de faire des
formules ou de faire plaisir à bruxelles
c'est parce que aujourd'hui rembourser
la dette française chaque année ça coûte
environ 40 milliards d'euros on parlait
à l'instant des fonctions régaliennes de
l'état
la défense en france le budget c'est 31
milliards d'euros 31 milliards 4 tout le
monde convient autour de cette table
qu'il faut renforcer le budget de la
défense nationale parce que nous sommes
en guerre comme l'a dit gilles on vient
écouter intensive ou renforcer la
défense de renforcer la police allait
reprendre où l'homme simplement
expliquer aux français qu'on peut
continuer à faire de la dette à la
mesure de ce qu'ont fait ces dernières
années et on remboursé plus qu'on n'en
consacre à notre argent de pour la
défense c'est pas possible c'est pas
tenable donc là les mesures de lutte
contre le déficit public sont
impératives
deuxièmement les redéploiements existe
et en termes de fonctionnaires c'est pas
supprimer toute la fonction publique il
faut pas tromper les français là dessus
mais on a à peu près tous d'accord sur
le fait qu' on peut avec des politique
de non-renouvellement des gens qui
partent à la retraite
un sur deux ou deux sur trois se
répandent des candidats réforme est pas
uniforme effectivement pas rabotée comme
on a pu le faire par le passé et c'était
une erreur
c'est pour toutes les fonctions s'il
faut ce qui s'est passé sur nicolas
sarkozy tu sais ce qui s'est passé son
remplaçant la fonctionnaire sur deux
lieux la suppression uniforme et tuzer
mais bien compris que je cherche un
point de différence entre vous entre
vous un mot quand même c'est que on va
hériter d'une situation dans lesquels
les socialistes n'ont pas du tout pensé
l'aménagement du territoire comme une
politique structurelle le seul
aménagement du territoire que les
socialistes ont fait ces dernières
années ça a été de redécouper les
périmètres des régions des communes des
cantons
un débat artificiel qui n'a pas fait
faire une seule économie
donc là il va falloir sans forcément
revenir surtout parce qu'on va pas
chambouler tout en permanence il va
falloir redonner de la visibilité à nos
collectivités territoriales parce que
c'est elle qui sont plus preuve des
besoins de nos concitoyens tout temps
probablement supprimer un des niveaux du
mille feuilles administratif français
puis le statut parce qu'on prend les
fonctionnaires on parle du statut des
fonctionnaires pas les fonctionnaires
eux mêmes ça va de soi à stoke
quand vous avez quelqu'un qui la
travaillent à l'état civil ou qui
ramasse les feuilles dans la rue est-ce
qu'il a encore la légitimité alors un
contrat à vie un contrat à vie
on se pose la question donc on supprime
le statut de la fonction publique
territoriale est pas la fonction en
elle-même j'ai le pack pourquoi est-ce
qu'on fait tout ça vous cherchez une
différence est déjà une expérience
on aura compris que sur la sécurité vous
étiez pas forcément d'accord l'asse
c'est moins net
moi j'essaie quoi ça perd encore des
gens pour garçons prennent ces moines
est à une condition pourquoi est-ce
qu'on fait tout ça pourquoi est ce qu'on
décide d'avoir moins de dépenses
publiques
moins de fonctionnaires comment est-ce
qu'on réorganise il ya trois maires ici
autour de la table on sait très bien que
on est toujours dans la réorganisation
permanent de nos collectivités ont fait
déjà ses efforts ce qu'on voudrait voir
faire par l'état demain mais pourquoi
c'est pour qu'on sorte de la spirale
fiscal nicolas sarkozy a proposé dès
juillet 2010 est une baisse de 10% de
l'impôt sur le revenu pourquoi tout
simplement
et j'en parle sciemment parce que
j'applique exactement la même politique
à chalon sur saône on a été je pense
danse et j'espère que mes collègues me
contrediront pas dans la taille de la
ville
la seule commune de france à voir
baisser ses impôts cette année et on va
essayer de continuer à les prochains
succès résulte en mieux nous ça fait 32
ans que ce n'était pas arrivé
non mais bien sûr mais c'était pas
c'était pas arrivé depuis trente deux
ans il est grand temps qu'on commence à
se dire qu'on ne peut pas ponctionner
éternellement sur les gens qui
travaillaient sur les gens tout court
et l'idée de baisser l'impôt sur le
revenu est également d'autres
allègements qui sont des allègements de
charges en direction de l'économie
notamment des bas salaires pour
favoriser l'emploi
forcément ça doit être financée par une
une rigueur budgétaire plus fort et
surtout un réaménagement la fonction
publique moi je crois à l'action
publique mais l'action publique et doit
sans cesse se renouveler
nous sommes dans une période d'argent
public tra nous devons en tirer les
conséquences pour réorganiser leurs
familles strasbourg différence là où
certains veulent augmenter la tva ou
baisser l'impôt sur le revenu bruno le
maire lui propose de baisser la csg la
cg qui repose sur tout le monde
les retraités les actifs quand un sdf va
chercher un sandwich dans son vol au
supermarché du coin ils payent les
impôts
avec la tva donc je pense pas que ce
soit d'augmenter la tva que ce soit des
premières mesures on a mesuré après un
chrétien c'est très bien qu'on nous
prend par la tva baisse certain nombre
d'autres charges qui permet de ne pas
augmenter les prix c'est un faux débat
et le vrai débat c'est de savoir si
effectivement on veut faire baisser les
impôts sur l'ensemble des français ou si
on veut déjà faire baisser dans un
premier temps et très rapidement l'impôt
sur les entreprises de manière à ce que
les entreprises puis recréer de l'emploi
parce que la vraie différence nous
amener au lac léman la vraie différence
dans notre société c'est ceux qui
travaillent et ceux qui ne peuvent pas
travailler et je crois que l'important
c'est de permettre à tous les français
de pouvoir retrouver un travail au
maximum à mon argent j'ai vraiment sens
sur ce qui a été dit puis sur ce sujet
là lorsque la priorité la priorité ça
doit être l'emploi c'est quand même ça
qui minent non seulement le monde du
travail en france mais c'est ce qui mine
la société française dans son ensemble
et quand on voit que nos voisins de
taille comparable allemagne le royaume
uni sont quasiment au plein emploi avec
des taux de chômage entre 5 et 6% là où
nous sommes structurellement nous au
dessus de 10%
c'est quand même le mal qu'il faut
combattre et pour combattre ce mal là
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire du coût du
travail de la durée du travail
évidemment avec une baisse massive des
charges qui pèsent sur les entreprises
et des cotisations qui pèsent sur les
entreprises et sur les entrepreneurs
parce que c'est ça qui aujourd'hui ronge
l'activité dans nos territoires nous
c'est pas forcément les grosses boîtes
du cac 40 qui vont relancer il ya déjà
eu beaucoup de chance pour les
entreprises un marteau rôle chez à
françois hollande d'avoir fait
c'est pas des cadeaux et tout était
contrepartie tout était histoire de
contrepartie chéché france et vous non
parentes repartent mais le cic l' usine
à gaz du cicr qui a été la principale
mesure vite cadeaux aux entreprises le
cic on a vu à qui ça a profité à la
poste aux entreprises franchement mais
ce que vous croyez que les travailleurs
individuels les petites les très petites
entreprises qui sont sur nos territoires
et qui elle voudrait embaucher parce qu
a pas un jour qui se passe où tous les
élus que nous sommes nous rencontrons
des gens qui nous disent on voudrait
bien on pourrait presque en termes de
volume de travail mais on le fait par à
cause de la complexité administrative de
la difficulté ensuite se séparer d'un
salarié si ça va mal et à cause des
charges essentiellement leur baisse des
charges d'accord les salles et charles 5
à 6 20 des 35 heures
enfin des 35 heures ce qui s'y connaît
pas en plus de souplesse dans la
fixation de la durée du travail et qu'il
a entrepris les autres parents et amis
es capable d'emmener sa valise et les
salariés puissent pas d'accord
entreprise par entreprise entreprirent
organiser leur temps de travail leur
annualisation donc c'est l'offre congé
différé donc très précisément ce qu'a
mis des français dans la rue contre la
loi travaille depuis un an et alors que
c'était la gauche au pouvoir
comment vous allez impôts des sas qui a
mis les français dans la rue
est ce que c'est vraiment la loi travail
ou le ras-le-bol général face à un
gouvernement qui a tout pratiqué en
matière de déchéance clairement les gens
protestaient travail sans consultation
sans citation présidentielle
si les sujets que nous sommes en train
de débattre arrive avec l'approbation
des français il faudra bien les mettre
en place il ya une grande sanction
électorale qui va arriver en avril et
mai sauf que chaque fois que la droite
gagne une élection derrière elle un
grand plan économique on se rappelle du
cpe on sera peut-être de la réforme des
retraites est derrière le pays s'y
opposent souvent en 2007 à 35 heures
nicolas sarkozy n'a pas supprimer les 35
heures suis désolé ce n'était pas dans
ses électeurs par les élections de nos
pattes
les électeurs de droite
la fin ils ont eu des heures sup
défiscalisées éviter le nous rétablirons
d'ailleurs écho la sarko là c'est qu'il
ya un retour on peut pas à la fois
supprimer 35 heures et réalise les
heures sup défiscalisées nous l avions
des heures supplémentaires défiscalisées
et il y aura une négociation dans
l'entreprise pour décider si oui ou non
on travaille au delà de 35 heures et
s'il ya des heures supplémentaires elles
seront défiscaliser c'est le système que
françois hollande a déchiré en arrivant
au pouvoir
je veux simplement dire c'est une chose
sur cette affaire des 35 heures on nous
dit sarkozy n'a pas mis fin aux 35
heures reprenez le programme de 2007
il n'y avait pas la suppression des 35
heures dans le programme c'est pourquoi
malgré les heures sup et non afghans
vont réaliser maintenant vous voulez le
faire non on rétablit les heures
supplémentaires défiscalisées et on
laisse à l'entreprise à l'entreprise un
référendum d'entreprise qu'elle
essaierait d'avenir dans les entreprises
qui le souhaitent un horaire qui sera
l'odarc travail de la fonction publique
on ne peut pas d'un côté avoir dans le
privé des gens qui vont travailler plus
de 35 heures et dans la fonction
publique
restait à 35 heures dans la difficulté
dans la difficulté voire la souffrance
qu un certain nombre de salariés ont
dans la fonction publique depuis
l'établissement des 35 heures pour
terminer en forme de ça pourra être
finalement un chapeau une conclusion de
cette émission dite dites-nous sur quoi
va se jouer de votre point de vue la
primaire est ce qu'elle va se joue de la
primaire de la droite est ce qu'elle va
se jouer sur la morale on a parlé des
affaires on as qu'elle va se jouer sur
l'idée du renouvellement d'une nouveauté
de ce qu'elle va se jouer sur une vision
du monde de la société ou peut-être sur
le refus du retour d'un ancien président
c'est peut-être le cas aussi chrétien
votre point de vue sur quoi vous savez
je crois que l'on peut pas demander des
efforts aux français si nous mêmes nous
ne faisons pas ses efforts et bruno le
maire
axe son début de quinquennat sur ce
référendum du renouveau démocratique
avec eux les des blocages administratifs
obliger les hauts fonctionnaires à
démissionner s'il veut faire de la
politique
les déblocages syndicaux mettre fin au
syndicalisme politique qui bloque comme
vous l'avez dit les principales réformes
le renouvellement politique fin du cumul
des mandats dans le temps
c'est extrêmement important la fin des
régimes spéciaux je note qu alain juppé
veut pas supprimer les régimes spéciaux
nous on veut les supprimer mais en plus
supprimer deux des suspects par deux
mais réputé lardons
c'est n'importe quoi non mais il voulait
pas le faire parce que ça lui rappelle
des mauvais souvenirs à nos noms mais
l'essentiel d'accord c'est le renouveau
de la classe politique si on veut
changer vraiment le pays il faut que la
classe politique se renouvelle en
profondeur
alors j pas trait de votre point de vue
ça va se jouer sur quoi et du point de
vue de nicolas sarkozy d'ailleurs au
quel but poursuit t-il dans cette
campagne une mauvais de leur présenter
ce matin donc je vais vous exposer le
point de vue nicolas seube est aussi lié
à ça tombe bien j'ai pas besoin de
forcer
ça va jouer je pense sur une grande
question qui transforme peut-être
beaucoup d'autres questions
il est bien évident que le chômage pèse
dans ce pays et que c'est une
préoccupation aujourd'hui pour toutes
les familles mais il y a un mal qui
ronge la société
c'est celui de l'identité et je suis
convaincu aujourd'hui et c'est
d'ailleurs une des grandes motivations
du vote
aux états-unis comme ailleurs dans
d'autres pays c'est une motivation du
break cite également en grande bretagne
aujourd'hui je le sent on le sent sur le
terrain
les français veulent se réapproprier ces
d'identité qu'on leur a volé on leur a
volé pourquoi parce qu'on a défendu les
minorité contre la majorité parce que on
a fait des accommodements et là je note
on n'a pas le temps évidemment ce matin
mais il ya de grosses différences sur
notre façon d'entrevoir entre les
différents candidats
la relation que nous devons avoir avec
la place des religions dans la société
là il ya des différences et des vrais
marqueur donc nous ce que nous
souhaitons avec nicolas sarkozy c'est
faire en sorte que les français
retrouvent le sens de l'identité
française ça passe par l'assimilation ça
passe par le respect de la règle
ça passe par beaucoup plus de coercition
par rapport à cet islam politique qui
nous ronge fondamentalement dans la
société et je crois très sincèrement
très sincèrement que c'est ce qui va
faire la différence les 20 et 27
novembre
arnaud danjean pour alain juppé ça va se
jouer sur quoi d'abord on sait pas sur
quoi ça va permettez moi de vous dire
encore une fois cet exercice de la
primaire il est inédit
les français qui vont voter d'abord on
sait pas combien seront ils les français
qui iront voter à cette primaire qu'est
ce qu'ils voudront exprimer
le vote pour alain juppé c'est un vote
qui tient compte du fait que la société
française est dans un état de grande
tension dans un état fracture est
divisée salariés contre patronat les
communautés entre elles rue rhin ruraux
pardon contre urbain ce la société
française est très fracturée et les
fractures et essentiellement
cause des incohérences des de ce
quinquennat qui n'en finit pas de se
terminer
qui est vraiment une catastrophe à tous
égards donc il faut redonner confiance
dans la parole publique dans l'action
publique qui va falloir agir pour
redonner du lien et du sens à cette
société française et je pense qu'il faut
quelqu'un qui a beaucoup d'expérience
pour faire ça quelqu'un qui ait beaucoup
de méthodes pour faire ça quelqu'un qui
n'ajoute pas du clivage à ses divisions
à ces fractures qui existent et qui sont
béantes aujourd'hui la société française
est quelqu'un qui saura mener encore une
fois avec expérience et sens du
rassemblement les réformes dont le pays
a besoin pour se retrouver on a entendu
trois représentants jean marie sermier
respecté et on va appuyer sur quel
levier
je crois que pour l'avenir de la france
il faut un programme françois fillon il
travaille depuis un certain nombre de
mois avec beaucoup de français qui l'a
rencontré au cours de ces trois
dernières années
2 j'ai pu d'ailleurs à ses côtés
peaufiner sur certains points et
françois fillon est prêt pour pouvoir
embarquer la société française vers un
plus évident mais en plus du programme
ce qu'il faut c'est un homme et françois
fillon avec son expérience avec sur la
netteté avec sa capacité à dire les
choses à dire la vérité est bien est
capable de pouvoir mettre en place le
programme qu'il propose et je crois que
c'est ces deux éléments là qui seront
porteurs pendant la primaire
merci messieurs de la venue participer à
ce débat bien trop court bien sûr pour
eux pour faire comprendre toutes les
différences qu'il peut y avoir entre
vous et les points communs aussi parce
qu'il y en a bien sûr rester avec nous
pour le flash de midi puis la deuxième
partie dimanche en politique en plein
dans l'actualité puisque ce sera alain
juppé l'invité de francis letellier et
la semaine prochaine on vous parlera de
la gauche et des frondeurs puisque ce
sera christian paul l'invité
de la bourgogne et barbara romagnan la
député du doubs qui sera l'invité en
franche comté
au revoir et bon dimanche
rien dans nos coutumes d' interdit aux
filles de renier faut les petits
français et les petites françaises
apprennent quelque chose qu'aucun autre
européen apprend à savoir que le
masculin l'emporté sur le féminin